Kobe Bryant quickly became a living
legend in the Philadelphia suburb where
he was first noticed for his basketball
skill he went straight from Lower Merion
High School in Ardmore Pennsylvania to
the NBA years later he made a large
donation for the school's new gym which
is named for him our national
correspondent Jericka Duncan is outside
the school northwest of Philadelphia
with the emotional reaction from
students and Bryant's classmates Jericka
good morning good morning to you today
will be the first game that the boys and
girls basketball team here at Lower
Merion will play since learning about
Bryant's death now we will know that
there will be a 33 second moment of
silence that's because Bryant Ward that
Jersey here at Lower Merion number 33 we
got a chance yesterday to speak to a
current student athlete as well as a
former teammate of Bryant's they all
explained why Bryant's spirit will live
on Kobe was us and we were him and I
think at Lower Merion High School
student athletes both past and present
tried to make sense of this loss
we played basketball on the same team
from my sophomore year so when I
graduated and remained friends ever
since then in the mid 90s Lower Merion
served as Bryant's launching pad for
both his NBA career and for his ability
to inspire I'ma stay focused on now I
wanna win a state championship so the
season rolls around
when you first heard the news what was
your reaction
guys Stewart played basketball with
Bryant for three highschool seasons and
considered the two to be brothers thank
you why him and why Giana
it was just during his four years at
Lower Merion riot led the boys
basketball team to its first state
championship and more than a half a
century we walk past his trophy case
every day and we never would have
expected it would happen this soon and
there's loss for words for everybody he
had so much more to live for it's so
much more though that's a strength
Jeremy treatment first covered Bryant as
a reporter he was reaction with David
and later becoming one of Bryant's
assistant coaches he was doing things
I've never heard of like getting a key
from a janitor and coming into the
school at four o'clock in the morning
five o'clock good morning taking 500
shots as a high school school student I
don't know anybody more successful in
their field that I've ever been
personally than Kobe Bryant you feel
lucky to have known him I do I do he
inspired me and we got a chance to speak
to some of those players who knew him
best after that news conference and I
asked each of them what do you think
Kobe Bryant is saying right now and one
gentleman's response stick out to me he
said he believes that Kobe Bryant is
saying keep going don't stop there's
still more work to be done yeah
television forward that's right Trika
thank you very much wait the capacity
that Kobe Bryant apparently had to touch
other people's lives and to make them
feel loved and special is unparalleled I
love seeing that High School footage and
seeing how fierce a competitor he was
then and how committed he was 500 shots
before school 500 shots after that's
what he used to see no it strikes me
guys how many people are claiming Kobe
Bryant yes in Pennsylvania they're
claiming him in Los Angeles they're
claiming I saw a report from Italy where
they are claiming what he did to unite
so many people you know I I hope he was
aware of how people felt about him in
his life I hope he understood the impact
that he made on a lot of people so los
ups about what the impact that we're
gonna miss I hope this family is feeling
that in some way too
Sarika thank you very much